ومن جانب اخر قال حكيمه الروسيه ان قصفا
اوكرانيا استهدف مؤسستين صناعيتين في
المقاطعه اوقع اربع ضحايا من جانبها افادت
وسائل اعلام دروسيه بتعرض عدد من القرى في
مقاطعه بيلكرود الحدوديه لقصف اوكراني ب
30 قذيفه مدفعيه
ونشرت مقاطع مصوره تظهر اعمده الدخان في
المناطق المستهدفه
هذا وكان حاكم مقاطعه بلكروده الروسيه قال
في وقت سابق ان حل مشكله القصف واستهداف
المقاطعه المتكرر يكمن بمقاطعه خاركيف الى
بيلرود واضاف
في مقابله مع قناه محليه ان 5 مجموعات
تخريب واستطلاع اوكرانيا تسللت الى
بيلجرود منذ بدء الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا
ما الذي يجب فعله لضمان امن مقاطعه
والمناطق الحدوديه يجب ضم خار كيف الى
مقاطعه
هل انتم موثقون من امكانيه تحقيق ذلك
هذه الوسيله الامثل لحل مشكله قصف
المقاطعه